Michael: All right,
good afternoon, everyone.
Welcome to the "Compliance
and Security in the Cloud" talk.
This is part
of the Google Apps track.
These are some hashtags
you can use
to tweet about this talk.
Uh, the picture I took
earlier of you all--
I posted it
with those hashtags.
Also, we're collecting feedback
for these sessions,
so this is the feedback link
you can use.
Feel free to submit
feedback anytime.
All right, so let me
tell you about myself.
My name is Michael Manoochehri.
I'm on
the Developer Relations team
supporting the Google Apps APIs.
That's my handle. Luckily,
my name is unique enough
for if you want to get ahold
of me, you can just Google me.
Um, and as you can tell,
my Android avatar
is a lot cooler than me,
wearing sunglasses,
and is a lot better dressed.
Um, now that I've
introduced myself,
let me, uh, find out
who you are.
This session will have
a lot of great information
for any users of Google Apps.
But, um, if you're
in this session,
I suspect you're one
of these folks.
You probably are Google Apps
domain administrators
or prospective administrators.
Possibly, you're enterprise
information managers.
I think there are some CTOs
and chief privacy officers
at this conference,
maybe some CIOs.
Um, you might be
system administrators
from government
and educational institutions,
large institutions
with thousands of users.
Um, and I know some of you
are Google Apps resellers.
You're, um,
independent software vendors.
There's system integrators here.
Um, if--if you're one
of these folks,
this talk is definitely for you.
Let me talk about what
we're gonna cover today.
Um, so the first thing
we're gonna do
is talk about what makes
compliance and security issues
so challenging.
We're gonna do a briefer view
about what Google Apps
provides out of the box
to handle some of these issues.
Uh, then I'm gonna introduce you
to the Google Apps
Administrative APIs.
And I'm gonna talk to you
about them in a way
that helps you address
some of these compliance
and security challenges.
Then we're gonna dive in
and look at some code.
We're gonna take a look
at three real-life use cases
involving policy, security,
or compliance challenges,
and we'll see
how these customers
use the Google Apps
Administrative APIs
to help address
some of these challenges.
So this is a 201 level session.
We assume
some technical background.
Um, but I'm gonna cover--
un-unlike some
of the other sessions
you've seen at Google I/O,
I'm gonna cover a very broad
range of technologies,
so while the code samples
I demonstrate
are gonna be quite simple,
um, I'm not gonna--
I'm going to assume
that you know
how to do your own
development environments,
or you're already familiar with
some of the technical issues.
You--you've heard
of some of the things
I'm going to talk about.
Um, and as a reminder,
this session is, uh--
the APIs used in this session
are only for Google Apps
for business, education,
government, nonprofit users,
not the consumer GMAIL accounts.
So let's start.
Let's remind ourselves
what Google Apps
provides for us.
What--what brings value to us
from Google Apps?
So first of all,
collaboration, productivity.
We're 100% web-centric, right?
So this allows for a lot
of great opportunities
for collaboration,
and that's--that's a great
value-add for you.
Also innovation--we're always
rolling out new features.
And you don't have to worry
about software upgrades.
It's automatic upgrades.
Um, platform independence--
a very big deal, right?
You're able to access
Google Apps
from your workstations at home.
Your employees can, uh--
can, you know--
on the road, travel, uh,
you know, independent--
independent workstations
where you're able
to access Google Apps
from there.
Um, but what's most important
for this talk
is less complexity.
Now if you were at the keynote
this morning,
you heard Sundar talk
about administrative costs,
and how that's a great deal
of the cost
for IT infrastructure.
And so what Google Apps provides
is reduced IT complexity.
We want to be the, um,
we want to be the less complex,
less-to-worry-about
solution, right?
So we--we have less hardware,
less licensing costs,
um, less need to, uh,
provide software upgrades
to disparate machines
across your network.
Okay, so you know all that.
That's why you're here.
Um, let's talk
about some security things
out of the box, like,
what about security?
Well, uh, Google Apps provides
the same security,
uh, and the same uptime
and infrastructure
used for our own
Google products.
This is great availability
and great security.
We also lower the barrier
of entry
to enterprise security features,
right?
So we have
2-factor authentication,
features like
SAML-based Single Sign-on,
which I'll cover in a minute.
Um, and that's great.
But just because
we can help you simplify
your IT infrastructure,
and despite the benefits
of Google Apps,
um, just becoming a customer
of Google Apps
doesn't solve all of
your information challenges.
Let me give you an example.
Can somebody in the audience
tell me who these two folks are?
And don't cheat
by using Google Goggles.
Anyone? No?
Anyone from a publicly traded
U.S. company?
Okay, no guesses.
This is Paul Sarbanes
and Michael Oxley, right?
[chuckles]
Some people do know
who these are.
So okay, besides being
dashing gentlemen,
um, and former congressional
representatives from the U.S.,
these are sponsors
of the Sarbanes-Oxley Act,
or--or SOX, as we call it.
So what did that do?
So that was U.S. legislation
passed in 2002
in part as a reaction to
the fiscal accounting scandals
from Enron and WorldCom.
Um, it increased regulations
on fiscal oversight
of publicly traded
U.S. companies, right?
Let's--let's see,
what actually happened?
Um, so SOX gave
the U.S. government agencies
additional powers to ensure
that proper fiscal compliance
and organizational controls
are being followed,
so stricter rules
around auditor independence.
Um, the audits
of organizational controls
was very important.
And I-I know not all of you
are from the United States,
and not all of you work
at publicly traded
U.S. companies.
But the point
I'm trying to make here
is this law passed in 2002
and changed everything
for the people affected by it.
Regulations can change quickly.
Compliance regulations
can change quickly
and standards come along
all the time.
Uh, also regulations differ
from country to country.
And what I'm trying say here
is that you never know
when these changes will occur.
You just have to be ready
for them.
So in the digital age,
fiscal compliance includes
information compliance, right?
Um, there's many questions
around some of these issues.
For example, if you're
an IT administrator,
you want to know, well,
what do my internal reporting
and control systems
even look like?
Um, how do I establish
a baseline
for standard certification?
Uh, how much does it cost
to audit my data?
So what are some risks
associated with user data?
You might have employee leaks.
You might have, uh,
security breaches.
How do you deal
with these things?
So these things are challenging
enough in a legacy setting.
But when you move to the cloud,
what tools do we have
to address
some of these challenges?
And that's really what this talk
is gonna be about.
Now apart from compliance,
there's day-to-day
security issues, right?
Are my users' passwords safe?
Like, how do I know if
an account has been compromised?
Um, what about
my identity management policy?
Do I already have one?
How do I plug Google Apps
into that?
And you're gonna find out today.
So here's--here's
the two takeaways I want to--
I want to leave you with
at the end of this talk.
And one is,
as I said before,
dealing with compliance
and security issues
often means being prepared
for the unexpected.
And the second thing
I want to tell you
is the Google Apps
Administrative APIs
are a set of tools to help you
address these custom challenges.
Okay, so let me introduce you
to the APIs
that I'm gonna be
talking about today.
Consider the typical actors
in your business environment,
right?
You have administrators.
Some of you are administrators.
You've all got users, employees,
people who interact with data
and services, right?
So these are, like,
documents, GMAIL calendars.
And then you have institutions,
and those institutions can be
your own company.
They can be regulatory agencies.
They can be, um, some kind
of school policy.
They can be legal entities,
and you need to deal
with them, as well.
You can't leave them
out of the equation.
So what the Google Apps
Administrative APIs do
is tie together these actors
programmatically
and let you create new tools
and services
to it--uh, to interact
with these actors.
For example,
I'm gonna introduce you
to the Provisioning API
and the Email Migration API.
These are used to create
and retrieve information
about users.
And the Email Migration API
is obviously
for deployment purposes.
For user settings, we offer
the Admin Settings API
and the Email Settings API,
and I'll get into those
a little later.
And finally, for interacting
with some of these
institutional actors,
we offer a Reporting API
and an Audit API,
and both of these are used
for reporting
and compliance purposes.
Okay, so why Google Apps
Administrative APIs at all?
We already have a control panel.
That's one of the other great
value-adds for Google Apps.
You can manage user accounts.
You can create
organization units.
You can provide
different access levels
of some of the services
we offer.
And we've recently added
some finer-grained
administrative controls
to this panel.
Right?
Well, the answer's obvious.
We--we want to give you
the ability
to create tools and services
to, you know,
automate context--
uh, complex tasks--
less "yak-shaving,"
as we call it.
Um, we want to allow Google Apps
to adapt to custom situations.
All of your--all of
your different needs
are--you know,
you have different needs.
You have custom needs,
and we want to make sure
that Google Apps can adapt
to those custom needs.
It's also a great platform to
build new software and services.
We have
the Google Apps Marketplace.
You can also build
independent software for people.
Um, and finally,
it's for growing a business,
providing services,
deployment services,
integration services.
There's great
opportunities here.
All right, so in general,
the Google Apps
Administrative APIs
that I'm gonna talk about
are only available
for use
by domain administrators.
Um, and as I said before,
they're available
for Google Apps for Business,
education,
government, and ISP users
and nonprofit users, as well.
And I'm gonna say just
a few words about authorization.
Authorization--
we suggest using OAuth.
Um, I'm gonna leave some
of the authorization steps
out of the--
out of the code samples I use,
because there's multiple ways
to authorize these APIs.
However, yes, we would suggest
using OAuth. Why?
If you've never heard of OAuth,
OAuth is a way to authorize
network services
without sharing passwords.
This is particularly important
for these APIs,
because all of these APIs
require administrator access.
And to--you want to share
those passwords
as little as possible.
Um, so OAuth requires
a whole separate session,
and some of you
have probably been
to the OpenID and OAuth session
that happened, I think,
just before this session.
If you haven't,
you definitely should check out
the video recording
of it later.
Um, it was given by Ryan Boyd.
Um, and I'm gonna say
another thing about OAuth 2.
Hopefully, you've heard
a lot about the OAuth 2 flow.
Um, that's great.
We're still working
on getting that flow integrated
into these APIs,
but we're working on it,
and we'll get that out soon.
For now, uh, the Google Apps
Administrative APIs
work with the OAuth 1.0 flow,
and we've just published
an article about using
the Provisioning API
with that flow.
So for more information,
I'll give you some links
at the end of the talk.
Now the Apps APIs also use
the Google Data Protocol.
Um, this is
an XML-based standard
derived from AtomPub.
If you've ever seen
an Atom, uh, newsfeed,
you kinda know
what it looks like.
Um, it's generally--these are
generally RESTful APIs--
create, update,
delete resources.
Just as an example, um,
this is the shortest
Google Data Protocol document
I could find.
Don't worry about this.
Normally you would interact with
the Google Administrative APIs
via, uh, libraries
and service classes.
And we have open-source
Google Data Protocol libraries
available for Java,
.NET, Python, PHP.
There's a few other languages
out there that we support, too--
or that are supported,
but not--not by anything
on Google Code.
And for the code that I'm
gonna demonstrate today,
we're gonna use the Google Data
Python Client Library.
All right,
so now I've introduced you
to the Google Apps
Administrative APIs in general.
Let's dig down and see
how they're used in practice.
I'm gonna share three stories
with you
involving actual
customer situations
with unexpected compliance
and security challenges,
and we're gonna see
how the Google Apps
Administrative APIs
were used to address
these challenges.
Let me tell you the tale
of the Google Apps reseller.
So I'm gonna introduce you
to my friend, Subradeep.
I've been working with him
for a while.
Subradeep is
a Google Apps reseller.
He works out of Bangalore.
He's also a, um,
system integrator.
He makes his business helping
people deploy Google Apps,
and he resells Google Apps.
He uses the Administrative APIs
to automate repetitive
administrative processes.
He builds tools for deployment.
He builds, um, alternate
administrative consoles
for his employees--
or for his customers.
And also, he uses these tools
to help with billing,
so he knows
how many user accounts
are being deployed on his
customer domains, et cetera.
So he has many customers
who want to migrate
their legacy accounts
to Google Apps accounts.
And, um, as--
you know better than I do,
as system administrators
or CIOs,
if you manage user accounts,
you don't save passwords
in plain text.
And even a casual observer
of, you know,
recent tech news,
knows that it's a bad idea
to store user passwords
in plain text.
Um, better to store
cryptographic caches
of the passwords,
uh, in case your user database
is compromised, right?
So in this case,
Subradeep often has customers
with, um, account information
that's in this format, right?
He has maybe a username,
maybe a first and last name.
And then he's given
a cryptographic hash
of a password.
And he's asked to move
these user accounts
to Google Apps with the pass--
hashed password intact.
This is a very common
deployment issue, right?
So how does he do this?
You know, he needs to move--
he needs to migrate
these accounts
without pre--while preserving
this hashed password.
He doesn't want to ask
the customers,
uh, the users
for their passwords again.
He wants to make the deployment
as seamless as possible.
How does he do this quickly
and securely without violating
that customer's
identity management policy?
Well, luckily, he can use
the Google Apps
Provisioning API.
This is the bread-and-butter API
of Google Apps.
And this API lets you create
and manage users,
groups, organization units,
nicknames.
Um, read and write access
is available
for the Google Apps
for business, um, accounts--
you know, .gov, ISP versions,
but it--this is one API
that's available
for all product versions
for Marketplace applications.
And use of this API
must be enabled
in the Google Apps
control panel.
It's a very powerful API.
Let me give you an example
of creating a user account
using this API.
Before we look at some code,
I'm gonna show you, um,
what's happening
behind the scenes
with the Google Data Protocol.
To create a new user,
we'd make a POST request
along with some data
in a Google Data document
to the following URI.
Oh, you would replace,
of course, "yourdomain"
with the domain in question.
What did we send
in that POST request?
Well, here's a Google Data
document, um,
that--that shows
the user creation data.
Let me highlight
the interesting parts.
Don't worry about the details.
So what we're doing
is we're gonna create
a new user named "susan_jones."
We're gonna provide
a cryptographically
hashed password.
We're gonna tell the API
which algorithm we've used
to hash this password.
And we're gonna give
a first and last name, as well.
Okay, so you wouldn't
normally do this,
unless you're writing
your own client libraries,
or you're running some kind
of shell script
from the command line.
What you'd rather do is use
the available client libraries.
So let's illustrate
what this looks like
using the Google Data
Python Client Library.
So the class used to make calls
to the Provisioning API
and the Google Data
Python Client Library
is called the AppsService.
We're gonna import
this service class.
We're gonna instantiate
a new object.
I'm gonna skip
the authorization step.
Once we have this, uh,
service class initiated,
we're gonna call
the CreateUser method.
And let me highlight
the same data fields
that I showed you
in the Google Data document.
Okay, so we are--
we're creating a new user
named "susan_jones,"
first and last name,
cryptographically hashed
password
with the MD5 algorithm.
The Provisioning API supports
both SHA-1 and MD5
hashed passwords.
So great,
that was pretty simple.
But normally,
it's not that simple.
Normally, you don't
just create one user account.
You create, uh,
10,000 at a time, a lot.
Um, oftentimes you might have,
you know,
a CSV file of usernames,
a database, something.
So in this case,
here's a list of tuples,
uh, representing
multiple user accounts.
We have the same thing--
Susan Jones,
someone named Larry Joe,
and you know,
thousands of others.
So how would we approach this?
Well, it's pretty simple.
Obviously, you'd run
a "for loop,"
iterate through the list
of accounts
and create--run the same
CreateUser method
on, uh,
on every single account.
Simple, right?
Well, no, it's not that simple.
Um, here's the first tip
I'll provide
for the Provisioning API.
And I'm gonna highlight
this tip,
because it's useful for the rest
of the APIs I talk--
I'm talking about.
Um, like many of the APIs
at Google,
we enforce rate limits,
but these--the rate limits
for these APIs
tend to change with capacity,
um, on our end.
So the problem with these, uh,
the problem that Subradeep
is gonna face
is the Administrative APIs
tend to be used
very heavily
in short bursts, right?
You're gonna make 10,000 calls
to the API as fast as you can,
or you're gonna change
every user setting
on a--on a huge domain.
Um, if you make quite a few
calls in a short time,
you may come up
against those rate limits.
And when you do,
you'll get a service unavailable
503 HTTP status message.
So how do we deal with this?
Well, we--we recommend using
some kind of back-off approach,
maybe an exponential back-off
or linear back-off.
Let me demonstrate
what that looks like.
I'll--I'll give you
a very simple example
of how to deal with this.
All right,
so Subradeep needs to import
some additional modules
to make this work.
Um, let's say he imports
some time modules
to help with some delay.
And he's gonna import
a class called
the AppsForYourDomainException
from the Google Data
Python Client Library
to handle exceptions.
Let's set two variables.
Let's set a delay variable.
This will be the amount of time
we wait before making a call
to the API.
And let's set
an increment value,
so this is how much time we're
gonna increment the delay,
if we hit that rate limit.
Let me show you what this
looks like.
Um, let's go back
to our "for" loop.
So here's our "for" loop before,
the one that we think, you know,
might cause some problems,
'cause we're gonna come up
against a rate limit
if we're provisioning
too quickly.
Um, we're gonna add
some additional code.
Let's add a "while" loop.
So if the user account
is created successfully,
no problem,
we leave the "while" loop,
move on to the next user,
everything's great.
If there's an exception,
we're gonna handle it.
Uh, we're gonna catch
that exception,
and we're gonna, um, figure out
what the cause of it was.
If the cause was a 503 status,
maybe because we hit
a rate limit,
or there might have been
some network problems
between the client and Google,
um, we're gonna increment
the delay value.
It's set to 0.
We're gonna increment it to 5.
We're gonna wait that long,
and then we'll retry it.
So if it works, great.
If not, we repeat
with a longer delay,
um, and, you know,
everything will be fine.
This is a simple--
this is just a simple example,
but I wanted to highlight this,
because this is
a very common question.
We get a lot
of administrators asking
how to do things
as quickly as possible.
Um, and in any case, you should
always use exception handling
when you're doing functions
like this.
Let me give you a few more tips
before we leave
the Provisioning API.
Um, newly provisioned users
take some time
to appear in the control panel.
A lot is happening
behind the scenes
when you create a user.
Um, here's another thing
you should know--
deleted user data--
even if you delete a user
through the control panel--
you probably may have heard
of this already--
or through the API.
It's held for five days
for security purposes.
This is another security feature
of Google Apps.
If you, um--if a--
if a user
kind of has maliciously deleted
or accidentally deleted,
five days usually gives us
enough time
to recover that account.
And one of the things
we're working with
with the Provisioning API
is to improve throughput,
so you don't have to worry
about these rate-limiting steps
at all.
So great,
so Subradeep's very happy.
He's--he was able to migrate
these user accounts
while keeping these hashed--
cryptographically hashed
passwords intact.
What about the e-mail?
So Google provides lots of tools
for e-mail migration.
We have IMAP migration tools.
We have migration tools for
different legacy e-mail systems.
But sometimes those tools
can't be used
for various reasons.
So someone like Subradeep
has experienced
many examples
where he was not able to use
the e-mail migration tools.
Maybe the IMAP server was down.
There was maybe
a firewall issue.
Sometimes the legacy e-mail
is in just some format
that he can't parse with
the normal migration tools.
For cases like this,
Google provides
something called
the Email Migration API.
So the Email Migration API
let's you move
your legacy e-mail to the cloud.
It doesn't just let you
move mail.
It lets you add labels.
You can add properties
like the archive status
of the message.
Is the message read or not?
Is it starred?
Um, this is one API
where non-admins can
actually use it themselves
if, uh, if the admin
gives that permission
in the control panel.
Um, and finally,
this API needs to--
can only use
UTF-8 encoded messages.
I've seen cases where people
try to use this API
with, um, alternative
character codings,
for example, Big5 for Chinese,
or CJK encoding.
To use this API,
it's best to encode--
or transfer
that character encoding
to a UTF before using it.
The other thing you need to know
about this API
is it only works
with RFC 2822 messages.
Now don't worry
about the terminology.
This is just the standard
for e-mail messages nowadays.
Um, this is the simplest
RFC 2822 message
I could come up with.
If you just look at, uh,
"Show Original" in GMAIL,
You'll see something
like an RFC 2822 message.
Don't worry about it.
The point I'm trying to make is
use the libraries
to create this.
If you need to create
a message like this,
JavaMail is a good use--
uh, a good library to use.
Um, Python has libraries,
as well.
Probably best to not try
to make these yourself.
But sometimes if you have
some files in mbox format,
the--the file--
the actual e-mails themselves
may be already in this format.
It's just a heads-up.
Let's see how to use this
in code.
We're gonna use
the same Google Data
Python Client Library.
The service class to use
is called
the MigrationService class.
Um, we're gonna import the ser--
the class.
We're gonna instantiate
a new object.
Let's grab one
of these e-mails from disk.
Um, so I already have
an RFC 2822 mail message there.
I'm gonna read it
into a variable
called "mail_message."
And here's the great part
about this API--
You don't just migrate it.
You can do things to it.
I'm gonna add some properties.
I'm gonna say,
This particular message
is going in the inbox,
and it's gonna be starred.
I'm gonna give it a GMAIL star,
and I'm gonna add a label.
I'm gonna add a label
called "migrated."
Let's put it all together.
I'm gonna call
the ImportMail method
of the service class.
In this case,
I'm migrating this mail message
into Michael's inbox.
I'm gonna add those properties,
and the mail message itself
is in the mail_message variable,
and that's pretty much it.
Now if you have a lot
of messages to migrate,
you can use the same strategy
that I illustrated before
with the Provisioning API
to do high-throughput
mail migration.
A few more tips for this--
uh, maximum size for
a migrated e-mail is 25 megs.
This includes attachments.
Um, and we don't allow migration
of any executable files,
even if they're compressed.
So Subradeep's been--
is very happy.
He's used the Provisioning API
and the Email Migration API
to handle these kind of
tricky customer cases.
Um, and before
we leave Subradeep,
let's add these APIs
to our toolbox,
um, of Administrative APIs.
We'll come back to these
in a minute.
Okay, so Subradeep's case was
pretty happy and pretty regular.
Let's talk about another, uh,
person who's
experienced challenges.
I'm gonna tell you the tale
of the university administrator.
I don't know if there's any
university administrators here,
but I know you work very hard.
So meet my friend Oscar.
He works at, uh--
as a system admin--
a head system admin
at a large state university
in this state.
He's got tens of thousands
of users.
He doesn't just have students,
he has administrators.
He has faculty, staff,
and he even gives out
alumni accounts to the alumni,
so he's got
a lot of user accounts.
So remember what I talked about
earlier with simplicity.
Oscar requires simplicity
in his IT infrastructure.
He doesn't want multiple points
of failure.
He wants to administrate
all user authentication
via a single--
single directory,
like an LDAP server.
He has many web-based services.
He wants Google Apps to appear
as just one
of many web-based services.
Let me illustrate what I mean.
So he has many services--
uh, web-based services
available to his students.
He might have
a student contact directory,
maybe a learning
management system,
and, uh, and maybe
a billing system.
And he wants to comply
with some kind
of university identity
management policy,
which is that all
of these services
must be authenticated
through a single source.
All right, so he doesn't want
his user authentication
to get out of hand.
He wants to use Google Apps,
you know,
but he can't deal with two
user authentication systems.
He wants all that auth
to be handled
through a university
login portal that interacts
with the LDAP server
that he set up.
He needs a single sign-on
solution for Google Apps.
What does he do?
Well...
he can use
SAML-based Single Sign-on,
which is a feature
of Google Apps.
It allows you
to incorporate Google Apps
into your existing
identity management policy.
Let me show you how it works.
So normally, users authenticate
themselves to Google Apps
through the familiar,
you know, login system.
Um, when you activate
Single Sign-on--
SAML-based Single Sign-on,
it delegates
all authentication duties
to the customer's
SAML-aware portal page.
Right?
Single Sign-on settings are
set through the control panel.
Um, essentially what you do--
what Oscar's done,
is he provides a redirect URL.
This corresponds
to his portal URI.
Um, Google Apps will
automatically redirect
the user's browser
to the university portal
when, uh, GMAIL or any Google
services are accessed.
Now SAML is a big subject.
I could probably talk
for two hours about SAML.
I'll suffice it to say if you're
interested in this feature,
um, we delegate all password
and authentication authority
to the customer,
including password changes.
Um, we adhere
to the SAML 2.0 standard.
And we only support
one type of flow,
and that is
the "resource provided--
provider"-initiated flow.
There's also
an "identity provider" flow.
We don't officially
support that.
I get that question
all the time.
Okay, so this is great.
So he's set up Google Apps,
um, behind his portal.
He's happy. It works.
So now he's got a problem,
and, you know,
maybe the problem--
if you've seen the headline
of the biggest newspaper
in the city today,
the headline was,
"California State University,
um, Tuition May Skyrocket."
Uh, the budget is tight.
The chancellor of the university
is conducting a financial audit.
He wants to know if they're
spending too much money
on IT support
for things like alumni
or extraneous IT support
that they don't need to pay for.
How many university
e-mail accounts are being used?
Are students using
POP and e-mail clients?
Do we need to support them?
Uh, what about alumni?
Do we need to waste resources
supporting alumni?
Are they even using
their alumni accounts?
Right?
So what Oscar needs to do
is compile a report,
a financial audit
on his department.
Who's using the university
e-mail system, right?
How many accounts
have been created?
How many students
are using their accounts?
How are they logging in?
How do you do this?
How do you do this
automatically?
All right, so he can use
what we call the Reporting API.
This allows you to generate
reports about user activity
on a Google Apps domain--
things like account creation
date, account activity.
Are people using the POP
or the IMAP clients
to access Google Apps,
or are they using
their web mail?
This is one API
that I'm gonna talk about today
that doesn't have
very good OAuth support.
Currently, we have to use
the ClientLogin interface.
We're looking
to improve this soon.
We also don't use
the Google Data Protocol.
We use a different XML format
to, uh, post information.
Again, you don't have to worry
about this too much,
unless you're writing,
uh, shell scripts.
Better yet to use
one of the available
client libraries to do this.
This is the, uh--
what the same call would be
using the Python Reporting API
Client Library.
It's very simple.
We also have Java,
.NET, and PHP clients.
Let me show you what an account
report kind of looks like.
Um, this is just an account
report for a single user.
Normally, you would get one
for everyone on your domain.
It's basically an easily
parsable text file
with comma-separated fields.
Um, let's look at what Oscar's
trying to find out.
He can write the script once.
He can parse out
the data he needs.
He can send
the chancellor's office
a weekly automated summary
summarizing the results.
So here, we have
the account name--
someone named "Michael"
who hasn't been using
his e-mail very much,
um, a last login date.
We can also get last POP,
you know, account,
if they're using web mail,
when this account was created.
So now Oscar can look
at this information,
and he can parse out
the necessary information.
He can even create
an automated script,
and send the chancellor
a monthly financial
audit report, right?
Now this is useful
for a university setting.
Imagine how useful this is
for companies, right--
huge companies who need
to lower their costs.
They want to get a handle
on what's going on
with their user accounts.
Which ones are being used?
Should we suspend accounts
that aren't being used?
Should we, you know,
should we take away
some accounts, 'cause
they're--they're, you know,
extra money in the budget?
Let me tell you
a few extra things
about the reporting API.
Um, the data is not real-time.
It might be up to 24 hours old.
What we do is we collate
the information
on everybody's domain
once a day.
Um, and depending
on when you call the API,
that data might be 24 hours old.
Um, it is meant for reports.
Um, these reports
can get big, too.
If you have thousands of users,
and you're getting
all this information, uh,
they can get pretty large,
so we allow you
to also send requests
to compress the reports,
um, using Gzip.
Um, okay, so this is great.
This has been really helpful,
and this is a really helpful API
for a lot of people
doing billing or other--
other kind of, um,
accounts requests.
Now Oscar has another problem
from the chancellor--
not as crucial.
The chancellor has an university
emergency alert system.
This is also an actual-use case.
The chancellor wants--
he thinks that what--
okay, let me explain the system.
The system is
if there's a fire on campus,
this alert system
will send an SMS message
to all the students,
and it will also send an e-mail
to their inbox
describing the problem.
The chancellor thinks
that these e-mails
are not conspicuous enough,
and he wants the e-mails
to be labeled "important"
somehow.
So Oscar is challenged
with the task
of finding a way to make these--
these particular e-mails
look a little more interesting
to the students.
What does he do?
How does he do such a thing?
Well, we offer two APIs
that can help with these things.
I'm gonna lump them together,
but they're two separate APIs--
the Admin Settings API
and the Email Settings API.
So these allow for bulk updates
of user e-mail settings,
also domain settings.
Uh, these are really useful
for building things
like deployment tools,
and, um, and automating
processes on your domain.
The Admin Settings API
lets you do things
like set the domain properties.
You can change
Single Sign-on settings.
You can change the domain logo
and a lot more.
What we're
really looking for here
is the Email Settings API.
This allows you to create
GMAIL filters, labels.
You can set delegation settings.
You can change user signatures.
You can set vacation settings
and more.
Um, just about anything you can
do in the GMAIL settings,
well, to a certain extent,
can be done programmatically
for any user on the domain.
Let's see what Oscar--
what Oscar needs to do
to use the Email Settings client
to fulfill
the chancellor's wish.
Um, so in the Google Data
Python Client Library,
the--the client is called
the EmailSettingsClient.
We're gonna import that client,
just like before,
instantiate the object.
We're gonna call
the CreateFilter class.
Let me highlight
the interesting parameters here.
Anything from the address
"chancellor@thedomain,"
uh, with the words
"Security Alert"
will be labeled "important."
And you can do other things
with this.
You can set
different properties.
We're gonna just use
the simple example
of setting a label.
This is pretty simple, right,
just a simple call?
How do we apply this filter
to everyone on the domain?
Let's go back to our toolkit,
and we'll grab
the Provisioning API again.
Remember, before, I said
the Provisioning API
can be used to create
user accounts.
It can also be used to retrieve
user account information.
We can use this API to,
uh, grab the user--
the names of everybody
on the domain,
iterate through the list,
and set the e-mail
settings filter
for everyone on the domain.
Let's take a look.
We're gonna call
the RetrieveAllUsers method
of the Provisioning API.
We're gonna put the, uh,
the information
into an object
called the userFeed.
userFeed contains
information about each user.
We're going to iterate
through the entries
in the userFeed,
and we're gonna pull out
the username.
And we're gonna run
that same CreateFilter call
on everyone on the domain.
Now like I said before,
it's important to--
um, don't forget to add
some exception handling,
as we did before.
We're gonna grab
that AppsForYourDomainException
handle,
and we're gonna handle the error
in whatever way we need.
So that's pretty simple.
Um, Oscar is very happy.
He's--he runs a tight ship,
and he has very little budget,
but these APIs allow him
to come up with some of the--
uh, to address
some of the challenges
the chancellor's office
has provided for him.
Um, we've seen how Oscar's used
Single Sign-on,
the Reporting API,
and these Admin
and Email Settings APIs.
So let's throw those APIs
into our toolkit
before we move on.
Okay, final story--
uh, a little bit sadder
than the others.
We're gonna talk about
the financial services CIO.
I wonder if there's
any CIOs in this room.
Maybe. Meet Carol.
So Carol works in San Francisco
as a CIO of
a financial services company.
I call this a small business,
but actually they're pretty big.
They're growing fast.
They handle investors'
corporate investments.
Um, she switched to Google Apps,
because she loved the fact
that she didn't have to worry
about, um,
you know, hardware,
software licensing.
It simplified her job.
And she wants her IT staff
to build a business,
not worry about
legacy e-mail servers
and licensing.
Great. Sounds wonderful, right?
Security's better.
But Carol has a problem.
Carol thinks one of her user
accounts has been compromised.
One of her employees
lost a laptop
in an airport in New York.
Now recall that her office
is in San Francisco.
And he did something
that you probably see a lot
with your employees
in that he kept a password
to his GMAIL account
in plain text on his desktop.
People use--do all kinds
of things with their passwords.
They might put them on stickies
and put them on their monitors.
Um, I've seen people
write their passwords
on the bottom of their laptops.
Um, so Carol has a problem.
She needs to find out
if she th--if this
account has been accessed.
Of course, she got the user
to change his password,
but what happened
in that 4-hour period
when he lost his laptop?
So Carol can use something
we call the Audit API.
And this is a very powerful API.
Um, it does
basically three things.
It allows an admin to download
an encrypted file
of a domain user's e-mail.
Also, you can grab
an account activity report
of a user, also encrypted.
Um, or you can create
an e-mail monitor.
This allows you
to silently forward e-mail
to another account.
Because this is an Audit API
meant for legal compliance,
all this happens
without the user
knowing what's going on.
This is meant for handling
legal issues,
compliance issues,
things like that.
As such, it's not useful
as a backup utility.
We only allow
100 requests for reports
a day per admin.
It sounds like a lot,
but on a big domain...
Before you--
since this is--
handles very sensitive
user data,
before you can use this,
you have to do more
than just authorize
through the API
with an admin account.
You must generate an OpenPGP
public-private key pair,
because everything that comes
back from this API
is going to be encrypted.
and the only person
who can open it
is the person
with that private key.
So before you do anything,
you must first take
your public key,
base-64-encode it,
and then upload it
to the Audit API.
You can't make any calls
for a mailbox dump
or an account activity report
without this step.
Now this is
a little tricky to do.
Um, we have instructions
on our web site
about how to create
these public-private key pairs.
But actually, uh, uploading it--
it's best to probably use
the client libraries.
Oh, and by the way,
before I get into this,
is Jay Lee here today
in the audience?
He's one of our open-source
client contributors.
He wrote some of the--
this part of the library.
Okay, just checking--I wanted
to give him a shout-out.
So the--in the Google Data
Python Client Library,
the methods to call, uh, reside
in the AuditService class.
We're gonna instantiate
that class.
Let's read
a non-base-64-encoded,
since this library
does it for you,
uh, public key from the--
from the, uh, disk,
put in the PGP key variable.
Now we're gonna call a method
called updatePGPKey.
And that's it. This will
upload the public key to Google,
so we can encrypt everything
we send back to you
with this key.
It only needs to be
uploaded once.
Once uploaded, we can make,
you can start making requests
for a mailbox dump
or user activity report.
What Carol needs to do
is make one of these
user activity reports.
This report
will allow her to see
when an account was accessed,
if logins were successful,
or were there failures,
and then what time
were they accessed?
So let's take a look.
Let's go back to the library.
I'll show you the code.
The first thing Carol does
is she uses
that AuditService class.
She calls the
createAccountInformationRequest
method on the user Michael,
who lost his laptop.
I've never actually lost
my laptop.
Um, what comes back is, uh,
is a status.
This is an asynchronous call.
Let me explain what's happening.
What's gonna come back
is a request ID
for this particular request,
a status message
about how--if this request
has been completed or not,
and some information
about the user, of course--
and, of course,
an admin account, too.
So this way, you can audit
the admins
who are making these requests.
The request--request I.D.
is very important,
because we're gonna
use that again.
Now we have to see if this
account activity report
has been completed.
The reason
that it's asynchronous
is because Google will go out,
collate all this information,
make sure it's right,
encrypt it,
and then provide it back to you.
We want to make sure
it's complete and correct.
Once you've created
an account request,
you have to go back and check
to see if it's complete.
Now an activity report is--
is just a list
of login times and IP addresses,
not very large.
It usually doesn't take
that long to complete.
A mailbox dump of gigabytes
of information
may take a long time,
may take up to three days,
depending on how much
information is out there.
We want an account
information request.
let's run the getAccount-
InformationRequestStatus method,
um, using the user Michael,
and we have to include
that request I.D.
If the status is still pending,
we'll get something
like what we saw before,
a "PENDING" status response.
Um, well, let's say
we've checked it again.
We're gonna get back
something like this.
So let's see
what the difference is.
The status is now "COMPLETED."
We have two new parameters,
right?
We have a number of files,
and we'll have a URL.
And the number of files
corresponds to how many--
well, the URL corresponds
to the activity report
or the mailbox dump,
and if these mailbox dumps
are very large gigabytes
of e-mail,
we'll split them up
into different files.
An activity report
is usually pretty small,
so there's only one file.
That's--that URL
is what Carol's gonna use
to download
the account activity report,
which is encrypted.
Let's check it out.
So Carol's gonna download
her activity report
from that URL.
It's encrypted, of course.
She has the private key.
She's the only one
who can uncrypt
this sensitive user data.
So she's gonna use
her private key
to decrypt the file.
It looks something
like this, right?
It looks like the output
of the Reporting API.
So the decrypted
accounts request file
is an easily parsable text file.
It includes information
about the user,
some services available to them,
as well
as additional information
about account login attempts,
date stamps, and IP addresses.
Let's zoom in
and take a closer look
to see what Carol sees.
So let's see, uh,
it looks like there's
some, uh, login success
and failure there at the bottom
for Michael,
who lost his laptop.
Uh, where's
the suspicious IP address?
Looks like maybe there.
Where is that IP address?
She's familiar with the, uh,
the IPs for the logouts
and the login successes.
Those are--it looks
like the IPs of the network
she uses in San Francisco.
So Carol can use a GeoIP lookup,
and she can see that the IP
for the suspicious login failure
was in New York,
where the--where the user
lost his laptop in the airport,
right? So you can see
why this is a very useful API
for doing these kinds of audits.
Sometimes you might want
to know, um, you know,
How many unsuccessful attempts
are being made
on some of our accounts?
Sometimes this is useful
for proving
that you have the ability
to audit your accounts activity.
Um, it's also important
for enforcing employee policy,
especially at a place like
a financial services company,
where this is regulated
by regulations like SARBOX
that we talked about earlier.
Okay, so sounds pretty sad.
Carol needs a stronger way
to protect her user accounts.
What is she going to do?
Well, she's gonna use
one of my favorite features
of Google Apps,
and that's 2-factor
authentication, right?
So normally, you log in
to Google Apps
with something familiar.
It's something you know.
It's your password
and your username.
2-factor authentication
adds another factor,
something you have, and most
of you have cell phones.
What 2-factor authentication
will do
is provide you
with a onetime password
every time you log in
to Google Apps on your phone,
by SMS or by an application
you can download.
It works something like this.
So normally, you put in
your password
and your username, like that.
Once you put it in,
and it's accepted,
you'll be asked to enter
a verification code.
And, of course,
this verification code,
as I just mentioned,
comes up on your phone.
That's the second factor,
and you're able to authenticate.
This is really useful.
This is an industrial-strength
enterprise security feature
that we bring to everyone
on Google Apps.
So for applications
that lack input,
we can use--
like, POP and IMAP clients.
We also offer something we call
application-specific passwords.
Um, and we also offer
the ability to create
backup passwords in case
you lose your cell phone,
and you need a way to get in.
So all of these things have been
thought out really well.
It's very useful.
Okay, so what have we done?
We've talked about
the Audit API,
and we've got
2-factor authentication.
Carol's very happy.
She loves these enterprise
security features.
She's got a small company,
also a tight budget,
and these have been very helpful
for her--for her business.
All right,
let's add the Audit API
to our toolbox.
Okay, so I-I've shared with you
three stories
about how the Admin APIs
are used to--
in various reporting
and compliance
and security issues.
Let's go all the way back
to the beginning of the talk,
and let's see what
all this means, right?
So earlier, I said that, um,
we--we offer great security,
availability, and uptime,
and we offer
great enterprise-level
security features.
But there's one more thing
I want to add,
and that is this toolbox
of Administrative APIs
for compliance and reporting.
So for you managers out there,
we're always improving
the extensibility
of Google Apps,
and the functionality
with new APIs.
And, uh, there's a lot
of exciting things
that are gonna come out
in the next year or two,
and I hope you stay tuned.
It's gonna be really great.
We depend on your feedback
to come up with these features.
And since regulations change,
compliances change,
standards change, we--we are
able to change with the times.
And for developers,
you have a lot of potential
customers out there, right?
Um, the amount of Google Apps
users is growing tremendously,
and there's
a lot of custom needs.
I just showed you
three different stories
of people with really
disparate needs.
But they're--they're crucial.
And sometimes people just
don't have the IT experience
to do what they need to do,
and that's where the developers
come in, like you.
We need you to build these tools
and build new products
to help these people.
Okay, so we're kind of
running short on time.
I'm gonna leave a little time
left over for Q&A.
Um, before we do, let me just,
uh, pitch a few things to you.
Um, so some of the documentation
about these APIs
I talked about
and the features--
they're available at
code.google.com/googleapps/docs.
Or just google for them.
Um, you can post feedback
at this feedback link
that I showed you earlier.
Please do if you have time.
We want you to stay connected.
the best place to look
for new features is to go to
the Google Apps Developer Blog,
which is at
googleappsdeveloper.blogspot.
And finally, we'd love you
to join the--
if you're a developer--join
the Admin API Developer Group.
It's, uh--there's a lot
of people in this group,
And it's--we respond
very quickly to questions
for the APIs.
And so go ahead and join,
and we'd love to hear your--
your feedback in there, too.
Okay, so that's
all I have prepared.
I'm ready for Q&A.
I hope you enjoyed the talk.
[applause]
Manoochehri: All right.
man: When the question
was asked about a year ago,
uh, Google was not considered,
uh, HIPAA-compliant
in terms of, you know,
protected health information.
Is there anyone at Google to ask
regarding direction
towards HIPAA compliance?
Manoochehri: Right.
So I-I'm probably
a bad person to ask about that.
Um, you should definitely talk
to one of our--
and I'm not sure
if they're here right now--
one of our PR people.
Or send a message to one
of our enterprise, uh,
enterprise representatives
on the Google Apps,
uh, enterprise page.
Um, so the problem
that we have sometimes
is I don't know
exactly which regulations
that, you know,
we're complying with.
They change all the time.
So, uh, but there are people
at Google that know
this information.
Yeah.
man: Great, thanks.
I just wanted some clarification
upon the limits, uh...
Manoochehri: Yeah.
man: Are those
for mailbox requests,
audit requests, or, like, both?
Manoochehri: Both.
man: Okay.
So it's 100 flat per day.
Manoochehri: Yes. Yes.
It's not meant to be used--
like I said before, not meant
to be used as a backup system.
And it's--it's doing a lot
behind the scenes.
So you have two limits
for that purpose. Sure.
man: Hi, two questions--
one on API in general.
Uh, is Google thinking
about, uh,
some sort of auditing--
the usage of the APIs?
If you imagine a fairly big
Google Apps account
of 10,000 users, probably...
Manoochehri: Yeah.
man: There's gonna be
more than one admin,
and there's gonna be
several admins.
And there's gonna be probably
third parties
that's gonna be accessing
my domain
and accessing my data
with APIs.
And maybe I would like to know,
you know, who's--
who's using which API when
for what data?
Manoochehri: Yeah. I mean,
yeah, excellent question.
Um, the answer is,
we're looking into it.
We don't have an API
that does this yet,
but it's something
we're working on.
man: And regarding the Audit API
specifically...
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm.
man: Um, I think the Audit API--
it's very powerful.
Nevertheless,
in the wrong hand,
it could be very harmful, also.
So is there any way to--
or is Google thinking
on some sort of workflow
on authorizing the usage
of the Audit API in--
or is there any way that I can
disable the Audit API
for--for a domain?
Manoochehri: Yeah.
Yeah, so the Audit API--
that's a great question.
Actually, the Audit API
can only be enabled
once you enable
the Provisioning API.
So you can actually disable it
in the control panel.
Um, as for what you said--
an ability to authorize it--
you said it's very powerful.
That's what that public-private
key pair is for.
It's almost like 2-factor
for an API.
man: Okay.
man: So we work with some people
who use PCI DSS
or under PCI DSS regulations
for credit card--
taking credit cards.
Um, and that seems to require
a continuous audit of logins,
um, whereas this appeared to be
just a single query
for an individual user.
Is there any thought to, uh,
a continuous feed of this--
somewhat like the syslog
I get from my own servers?
Manoochehri: How continuous?
Well, so let me answer
your question twice.
No, we don't have an API
that does that.
Um, and the Audit API--
you're right.
It's not something
that works continuously.
It doesn't push-notify anybody
about an account access.
But in your experience
with PCI compliance,
how continuous
are you talking about?
man: Well, what we get
currently is, you know,
this guy logged in,
then this guy logged in,
so it's a--
it's a pretty continuous flow.
I'm not sure whether
the regulation would--
I mean, it would probably be
satisfied if you could
do a poll once a minute and get
all the logins that happened.
But it's mostly
that it's looking
at everybody's account...
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm.
man: Pretty rapidly.
Manoochehri: Well,
I'd like to talk to you
about the requirements of that.
The short answer
to your question is no.
The Audit API doesn't actually
provide that functionality.
woman: A question
about Single Sign-on.
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm.
woman: Uh, there's a link
you can link to use
that you do the Single Sign-on
and also sign out.
So for logout, usually,
you know, we do--
try to, uh, delete cookies
and things like that.
Do you have a reference
how to do that?
Manoochehri: Right.
So, yes, let me--
let me say something about that.
Google Apps doesn't support
Single Sign-on--
I'm sorry,
Single Sign-out functionality
for various reasons.
Um, one is because once
you sign out of Google Apps,
we don't want--we don't know
if you've signed out
of everything completely.
We leave that all up to you.
Um, for a reference, there's
two softwares you could look at.
I don't know if you use
Shibboleth or SimpleSAMLphp.
woman: Uh, Shibboleth.
Manoochehri: You use Shibboleth,
okay.
So that--this is a limitation
of Shibboleth, as well.
Um, the real--the only real way
to do Single Sign-out
is to actually create a function
that closes the browser window
when you've signed out.
You probably
have seen that already.
Um, the answer is, Google Apps
doesn't do anything for that.
I think you should look
at what SimpleSAMLphp does,
which is attempt to, you know,
sign everything out,
sign everybody
out of every service
once the sign-out link
is--is clicked.
woman: Okay, uh,
second one is simple.
The Reporting Python library
that you just showed...
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm.
woman: Does not seem
to have IMAP.
Manoochehri: Does not seem
to have what?
woman: IMAP session, IMAP login,
last IMAP.
Manoochehri: Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah. So we--
woman: You have last POP,
but not IMAP.
Manoochehri: Right, we com--
as far as I know--
I might be mistaken about this,
but I think we combined
the IMAP and POP, uh,
the IMAP and POP accesses
in that--in that one variable.
woman: So the--
Manoochehri: So it's basically
web mail versus non-web mail,
is what that reports.
woman: Okay, so last POP
maybe is last IMAP, right?
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm. Yes.
Oh, I see.
There's no differentiating
on our end
about is it POP versus IMAP?
It's just--it's just
an e-mail client versus--
or, I'm sorry,
a desktop e-mail client
versus a web mail client.
woman: Okay. Um...
Manoochehri: Do you have
a requirement
to separate those two?
woman: Well, it's just
the title is confusing.
I can go back
to do some testing.
I studied just POP.
Manoochehri: Yes, it's--
I agree that the label
is slightly misleading.
woman: Yeah. Um, the other APIs
that you named--
Provisional--Provisioning API
and all the EmailSetting
and all that...
Manoochehri: Uh-huh.
woman: Do they--do they
support OAuth 2 or OAuth 1?
Manoochehri: Um, everything
that I talked about
supports OAuth 1
except for--or--is--
uses OAuth 1
except for the Reporting API.
Um, OAuth 2 flow
is not supported
by any of these APIs yet.
We're working on that right now.
And I hope to get that
soon, actually.
woman: Okay, OAuth 2
is not supported yet.
Manoochehri: Right, exactly.
woman: But OAuth 1 is okay.
Manoochehri: Yes, the OAuth 1--
Yes, the OAuth 1 flow
is supported with these.
woman: Okay, thank you.
Manoochehri: Oh, let me add--
I said this earlier,
but there's--we just published
an article about using
OAuth 1 flow
for web-based applications
with the Provisioning API.
If you're interested in learning
more, that's a great resource.
man: Hey, um, when you,
um, get the dump...
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm.
man: For an e-mail's mailbox...
man: And you decrypt,
does that decrypt everything
into clear text?
Manoochehri: Say that again.
I didn't hear the last part.
man: Sorry,
so when you decrypt...
Manoochehri: Uh-huh.
man: The user's mailbox...
man: Do you see everything
in clear text?
Manoochehri: Yes.
man: Everything?
man: Okay.
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm.
woman: Uh, I had
a quick question,
kind of along the lines
of the gentleman
who was talking about PCI DSS.
Manoochehri: Yeah.
woman: Have you seen
any implementations
where the, uh, people are
using the Google Apps engines
to keep track
of, uh, which users
performed which actions
in the system,
so that you have an audit trail
for all the activities
that took place, for example,
on a partic--
if you're in financial services,
for example...
Manoochehri: Yeah.
woman: For each of your
customers, you need to have
a-an audit trail for who made
changes to the account.
Manoochehri: And which type of--
so were you talking about
administrative functions, like--
woman: Um, yeah.
Basically, if you're a customer
service rep, for example,
or, uh, if you're
in fraud management...
Manoochehri: Yeah.
woman: And you make
a change to the account,
you know, you block it,
or you, uh, you block
the person's card,
you change their address,
you change their date of birth,
that type of thing...
Manoochehri: Ah, yeah.
woman: You need to be able
to look in the system
and see who made the change.
Have you seen
any implementations
with Google Apps engines that
use that kind of functionality?
Manoochehri: I'm not
familiar with any.
Uh, it's something that we get
asked about from time to time,
and it's something
we're looking into on our end
for different ways
to audit things
that are not user accounts,
but actually
administrative actions.
And that's something
that we're looking into,
but we currently don't have
a particular API
that does that yet.
woman: Okay, thank you.
man: Hello.
Um, I'm just wondering
why the chats in Gtalk
are not auditable?
You--you cannot get it--
well, with the Audit API
you get it,
but only if the user
has their setting,
like to store a chats history.
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm. Oh, the--
man: And the administrator
cannot force the users
to keep the chat history.
Manoochehri: I see. Yes,
this is an interesting question.
So, uh, it's kind of like,
a 2-part question.
One, actually, the Audit API
will let you download
a dump of chats that were,
um, on the record.
But you're asking basically,
Can we force chats
to always be--
is that what you're asking?
man: [speaking indistinctly]
man: Yes.
Manoochehri: So these kinds
of additions to Google Apps,
these kinds of requests
for things--
we're also looking
into different ways
to do these things.
Again, I don't have an API
that will provide you
with that information,
but it's something
that we've been asked about,
and we're looking
at the possibilities
with these things.
man: Thank you.
Manoochehri: Mm-hmm.
All right, so I guess
there's no more questions.
I don't want to run
out of time here.
I think you guys
should go out
and enjoy the rest
of Google I/O,
and let's call it a wrap.
How about that?
All right. What's that?
[applause]